the Joe Rogan experience who else Alex
Jones suppose downloads Alex beat
everybody by really fuckload yeah man it
was interesting so here's my theory on
Alex Jones just if you want to go there
okay I love going there so I think he's
a government plot he's not I tell you
that for sure I've known him forever
I've known Alex since 1998 he's not but
I couldn't lot because she would tell
everybody he's not hung out with that
guy get high with him drunk with him
he's a fun dude he is a guy who started
out as a guy who is against the
president he was against george w bush
with w bush i don't even think he was
praised running for president at the
time right or was he when he was it when
did Bush become no Clinton was president
yeah Clinton was president george w was
the governor of texas and he was getting
arrested for protesting against them
protesting against the global ëletís and
all these different things he had didn't
really become a supporter of any form of
government until trump I mean Trump is
like the first guy and he may or may not
be getting played by Trump or you know
Trump's his buddy and I mean Trump is a
he's a slick guy in terms of how he
cultivates influence that anomaly for
sure he's an interesting character in a
lot of ways I mean if it wasn't okay so
she's got my theory that completely it's
just a theory I'm not I don't
promulgated as this Factory okay I've
always thought the Alex Jones was was
built by the government to make
conspiracy theorists look like loons he
didn't used to make them look like loons
no no he was much more my story with
9/11 though right no no way before no
but I'm sure with Waco but that's when
he came to prominence right like ooh
because he was the first to know even
before then man you know I mean with
nobody cared about it before he was on
AM radio before then right but he's been
around forever I mean like I said I met
him I'm not wrong then I met have been
ninety-eight so it was several years
before 2001 and he was doing the same
[ __ ] back then nice I mean he's always
been around doing that he's he's right
about a lot of [ __ ] and that's what's so
confusing like he is absolutely right
about what they call agent provocateurs
where the government will send in people
if they have a peaceful protest it's
very inconvenient for them like the WTO
he did this whole video about how the
WTO was that in Vancouver or Seattle
where was the WTO I forget where it was
why don't want is somewhere in the
Pacific Northwest I'm confused but I'm
not confused about the story so what
happened was they had these peaceful
protests against the World Trade
Organization and it was very
inconvenient all these world leaders
were coming to this this area for this
meeting and they sent in government
agents that were dressed with black
black ski masks and government-issue
boots and these people started smashing
windows and lighting things on fire they
turned into a violent protest which
enabled the police to close in and shut
down the protest your WTO protests where
did it say Alex Jones police state to
the takeover Seattle yeah was yeah no
okay so they this it but this is a real
tactic that governments and intelligence
agencies use they have a peaceful
protest and then they have these people
like they these guys dressed in black
ski masks they start tipping over
newspapers test like it doesn't even
make any sense like em they're they're
they're government agents meanwhile the
these guys have government-issued boots
no it goes further so these guys all
they all got together at the end and
they were cordoned off into a building
and then they were ultimately released
they were never charged
they were never arrested I mean the
whole thing is incredibly fascinating
and some of them have been identified as
government agents and Alex way more into
detail about it that's why uh you know
I'm not a conspiracy theorist so to
speak but the one thing I always say is
I don't put anything past our government
there's absolutely been conspiracies
that are real for sure especially
whether it's the Gulf of Tonkin incident
yeah whether it's Operation Northwoods
there's been and there's I'm sure
there's been a bunch
we don't know about I believe that the
government assassin or somebody
assassinated JFK I don't think it was
Lee Harvey Oswald I'm alone I think it's
very possible Lee Harvey Oswald was a
part of it but I know too much about
bullets to think that that [ __ ]
bullet went through two people and wound
up on Connolly's gurney in the hospital
looking pristine cut the [ __ ]
that's all I don't think that's real at
all no I've seen this is a pruder film
I've read several books on the story I
just I think it's very convenient to
lump all that into one guy with one
bullet I think it's horseshit and I
think they probably killed him all right
don't say always always look into a
little bit you know and then I'm like
you know what the government PI did this
[ __ ] whatever [ __ ] they probably did a
lot [ __ ] that we don't know about
they're not aware of if this is how
governments work they've always worked
like does intelligence work the smart
criminals go to politics the dumb
criminals go to jail right there's a lot
of that especially a lot of that
[Applause]